le président du sénat gérard larcher
l'invité de preuves par 3 bonsoir
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous pour
ce rendez-vous de public sénat avec l'
agence france-presse et dailymotion
la grèce bien sûr au sein ou en congé de
la zone euro c'est la question qu'il
convient de trancher et vous nous direz
gérard larcher quelle est votre position
avec guillaume daudin de la fp nous
ouvrirons la page des républicains alors
que le débat safin la lutte aussi entre
le les prétendants à 2010 est enfin avec
perrine tarneaud de public sénat nous
évoquerons le travail parlementaire et
cette offensive pour une procédure plus
rapide plus réactive c'est là par
exemple le voeu de françois hollande
vous pourrez lui répondre tout à l'heure
la grèce d'abord bien sûr gérard larcher
faut-il sauver sa place dans la zone
euro l'avenir de la grèce appartient au
gouvernement grec et donc sa place dans
l'europe et dans l'euro et il s'est mis
un peu dans une situation impossible non
pas que le référendum est pour un
gaulliste une voix normale de
consultation mais en fait qu'est ce qui
va se passer
soit le gouvernement grec vient avec des
propositions qui répondent aux
propositions faites par les pays
européens qui en fait oui à la
solidarité mais il y a des règles et dom
des réformes
il faut conduire d'autres pays l'ont
fait en irlande lettonie portugal ça a
été des moments aussi difficiles
douloureux et ou alors la grèce vient
les mains dans les poches et ne fait pas
de proposition et donc je crois que pour
l'europe
c'est un moment important de réaffirmer
à la fois sa solidarité mais aussi qu'il
ya des règles qu'il faut respecter et
donc personnellement je souhaite que
l'axé franco-allemand qu'on sent parfois
un peu inégal entre unia des positions
claires une france et un président de la
république dont on sent pas toujours
très bien entre solidarité
responsabilité qu'elle est calé son
choix et bien que se dessine
une décision certains vont évoquer bien
sûr la grèce dans l'europe avec une
sortie de l'euro mais qu'ils soient
sorties accompagnées j la grèce parce
que ça fait ça dure depuis cinq ans
quand même cette affaire si la grève se
mais vous devez fait par exemple le
ministre grec des finances le nouveau
est arrivé à bruxelles sans proposition
sans document écrit avec quasiment les
mains dans les poches crois qu'il faut y
mettre un moment mais ils actionnent
impossible il faut être sérieux
de part et d'autre rappeler cet
équilibre entre solidarité et sens des
responsabilités
donc la capacité pour les grecs de
conduire des réformes savait pas quand
même à certains de choses qui n'ont
jamais été fait en grèce je le répète
quand le niveau des retraites est
comparable au niveau des retraites
allemande et qu on ne réforme pas le
système des retraites
quand il n'y a pas de cadastre quand il
y a un retard de près 80 milliards dans
la collecte de la fiscalité
quand une partie de l'économie grecque
quelle économie notamment des armateurs
quand une partie aussi de la vie grecque
qui est l'église orthodoxe échappent à
l'impôt en dickens est aussi riche que
le montant de la dette aujourd'hui je ne
sais pas et je ne vais pas me lancer
parce que c'est aussi un élément très
important de l'identité grec de la
culture grecque
mais il ya un moment il faut que ça me
rappelle des débats que nous avons eus
il ya bien longtemps au moment du traité
de maastricht
quand philippe seguin et je faisais
partie de ceux qui l'accompagnaient
d'inattention convergence fiscale
convergence sociale il va falloir que
réellement il
on y travaille si on a une bonne et
unique et chante pasqua gelé rappelé
l'autre jour disait à la même date il ya
25 ans oui c'est quand même cette
réalité là ils commenceront les
convergences pourquoi je cite les
finlandais les grecs bas on a une heure
de rendez vous donc la situation de
toutes façons appelle à une plus grande
convergence économique de la zone euro
mais économique sociale fiscale alors
vous avez évoqué effectivement le couple
franco-allemand gérard larcher c'est un
point très important pour la solidité de
la zone euro
c'est cette force
de ce couple or est-ce que vous
incriminez donc plus clairement
françois hollande qui a joué au
conciliateur à tout prix oui je peux
comprendre qu'on ait envie de considérer
quand même regarder ce que celui-ci
prince a été élu dans des conditions
dans lequel il a promis de supprimer la
taxe foncière dans lequel il a
revalorisé des retraites qui avait déjà
un 13e et un 14e mois qui a ensuite
promis des embauches de fonctionnaires
tout ça n'est pas raisonnable toqué un
moment entre amis c'est à dire un peu
quand même disputé fasse des
propositions sérieuses raisonnable et
qu'ensuite il ya l'expression face à ces
propositions sérieuses d'une décision de
solidarité à la condition à la condition
que la grèce assume ses responsables se
dossier révèle une trop grande fragilité
du couple franco allemand
je crois que dans la gestion de ce
dossier on a bien vu qu'il y avait
parfois des dissonances
mais quand il y à des convergences alors
l'europe est forte et l'europe est forte
de la convergence franco allemand ce que
je constate c'est que nous avons une
inégalité entre le couple franco
allemand dans cette expression
d'exigence ça me choque mais il est
naturel que nous soyons exigeants
vis-à-vis de la grèce intransigeant même
10 des demandes est en berne à bernac
exigeant mais parce que il ya un moment
il faut exiger et en même temps une
solidaire je crois que c'est la réponse
qu'il nous faut trouver et on verra ce
que demain le gouvernement dira lors du
débat notamment au sénat demain après
midi
alors donc effectivement puisque manuel
valls a annoncé le débat à l'assemblée
nationale il y aurait également un débat
bien sûr au sénat et si on demandait aux
opinions publiques et aux parlementaires
de se prononcer et éventuellement sur
des aides supplémentaires demain à la
grêle or ce n'est pas dans notre système
constitutionnel
je dois vous dire que je dis au ministre
en charge des relations avec parlement
en début d'après midi que si un jour on
est face à des décisions
il faudra pas qu'on se contente d'un
débat sans vote qu'il faudra voter 6-1
au plan daide si un nouveau plan daide
ou l'uci à une décision de sortie de
l'euro il est bon que le parlement
puisse s'exprimer
même si ça
et pas une injonction au gouvernement
dans le système de la vème république
très bien le souhaite je les dis
ministre en charge des relations avec le
parlement
cet après midi est ce que le non massif
lors du référendum de dimanche était
pour vous un nom à l'euro c'est d'être
avec eux c'est un peuple aussi qui a
fait beaucoup d'efforts qui a le
sentiment que ces efforts n'ont pas été
récompensés
mais il ya une telle dette cumulée on ne
sait même plus je lire si ses 230 330
milliards la part publique la part
privée
on sait que aussi il va falloir pour la
grèce pour suivre un certain nombre
d'efforts et ça ne peut pas se faire par
un effacement de la dette sans
contrepartie de réforme mais qu'est-ce
qui est le plus préférable à ce stade
selon vous gérard larcher pour la
solidité de la zone euro est ce qu'il
faut effectivement un départ négocié une
mise en congé de la grèce pour la zone
euro que des règles claires et des
règles qui c'est la meilleure façon de
les réaffirmer à la commande soit m
qu'ils soient posées si le pays ne
respecte pas il faut en tirer les
conséquences des règles sont faites pour
être respectées les règles peuvent être
j'allais dire adapté à la dimension
aussi sociales et humaines parce que je
ne doute pas de la souffrance potentiel
du peuple grec mais si le peuple grec
sort de l'euro alors les souffrances
sont encore plus grandes
me semble-t-il et non pas sera un plan
des manies terre comme le dit je vis
sans faillir divinis grec prenne ses
responsabilités on peut pas jouer au
bluff on peut pas jouer avec le peuple
et ne pas engager les réformes qui sont
nécessaires alors il ya des mots très
durs évidemment qui sont prononcés dans
votre camp cherche à l'encontre d' alex
et 6 passes mais mais pas que puisque
dominique wiel pas à une autre vision
il lui parle vous avez fait référence à
vos références gaulliste vos racines
gaulliste il ya un instant gérard
larcher il me parle comme gaulliste
d'innover nique de villepin il trouve
qu'il a le mérite d'avoir donné la
fierté au peuple grec
il a donné la parole au peuple grec mais
derrière qu'est ce qui va lui apporter
au peuple grec
il faut qu'il ait le courage de réformer
il faut qu'il ait le courage de sentir
son pays il suffit pas de dire oui ou
non il faut maintenant gouverner et
gouverner c'est s'engager en
responsabilité et on ne peut pas faire
des promesses qu'on dirait pas financés
en direction du peuple grec
je ne voudrais pas que ça soit un espèce
de référendum ou bout du compte ce soit
le peuple grec qui soit sacrifiée alors
vous venez d'exprimer votre position sur
le dossier grec mais j'ai noté qu'il y
avait des divergences d'approché au sein
de votre parti des républicains
parce que vous y comprenez quelque chose
et quelle est la bonne ligne celle
d'alain juppé celle de nicolas sarkozy
qui lui se montre également plus tôt
ouvert au dialogue social à la dernière
ligne droite vont à durer je ne vois pas
de véritable divergence sac chacun dit
qu'il va falloir que la grèce respecte
des règles communes que nous avons dans
la soudure ou non mais à la gpei les
pour le grec cite par exemple il allait
virer ça me dire qu'ils font un dernier
tir et les conséquences je n'ai pas
entendu que sa décision soit l'expulsion
de la grèce de la zone euro
il ya un moment simplement avoir le
courage de la vérité bon alors on va
évoquer maintenant plus largement les
républicains avec guillaume daudin de l'
agence france-presse qui va nous
rejoindre le président du nouveau parti
nicolas sarkozy n'est pas toujours suivi
on constate semaine après semaine par
les sénateurs dans sa vision de
l'alternance faudrait vous états c'est
son mot d'ordre pour préparer 2017
nicolas sarkozy va jouer la carte du
clivage gauche-droite exacerbée avec une
promesse la plupart des réformes de
françois hollande seront abrogés si la
droite revient au pouvoir
dans sa ligne de mire notamment la
réforme territoriale
mais les sénateurs hésitent
et les élus n'en peuvent plus c'est vrai
que cette instabilité législatives les
élus n'en peuvent plus mais à partir du
moment où un texte fait des erreurs on
est parfaitement légitime à pouvoir les
rectifier dans un deuxième temps
et si pour nicolas sarkozy l'opposition
systématique et le clivage son sein pour
la démocratie
pour fabienne keller il faudrait aussi
joué la carte du rassemblement
il a son caractère et sa personnalité
donc ils souhaitent faire des
propositions fortes parfois clivante
pour ma part je pense aussi que le
rassemblement l'apaisement sont
nécessaires aujourd'hui à une franche
très secoué 13 en recherche en fait
d'apaisement et de consensus pour
pouvoir mettre en oeuvre des mesures
indispensables leur liberté de parole
les sénateurs républicains y tiennent il
y à un mois ils l'ont fait comprendre à
leur président nicolas sarkozy voulait
que l'assemblée et le sénat déposent une
proposition de loi commune contre toutes
les dispositions du gouvernement qui ont
étouffé les entreprises
christian jacob a donné son accord -
d'emballement du côté du sénat on n'a
pas le même méthode de travail que
l'assemblée on a une réflexion que d'une
réflexion de fond et je pense qu'il faut
respecter ce rythme là pour ne pas
sacrifier le fond à la forme ou à la
précipitation c'est tout alors
indisciplinés les sénateurs républicains
vis-à-vis de leur président il ya une
liberté de ton une liberté de position
et une liberté de vote allaient auxquels
les sénateurs tiennent beaucoup voilà ça
ne veut pas dire que les sénateurs sont
plus indisciplinés ou plus indépendant
que
les députés ou que les militants général
mais il ya une responsabilité un peu un
peu différente pour un tir groupé des
parlementaires républicains il faudra
donc repasser
voilà pas de tir groupé donc des
sénateurs républicains derrière nicolas
sarkozy se rencontrent en bon soir
guillaume noda vos questions au
président du sénat bonsoir donc on l'a
vu là dans le sujet là la réforme
territoriale est en débat est ce que
vous pensez qu'il faut revenir sur le
dernier texte qui a été acté par exemple
revenir sur la mesure la plus
emblématique les 13 régions
écoutez d'abord peut-être qu'augmenter
ce que je viens d'entendre c'est vrai
que le sénat et ses d'intérêt d'avoir
deux chambres élues de manière
différente
élu en un temps différent ça n'est pas
la réplique sismique de l'élection
présidentielle comme l'assemblée
nationale
élus représentants de territoire qui les
sépare jaillir d'autonomie de liberté
oui je la revendique c'est d'ailleurs
sur cette ligne là que j'ai été élu
président du sénat
d'accord mais en même temps j'appartiens
à une famille politique
à l'intérieur cette famille politique
j'exprime ma sensibilité je porte la
sensibilité des sénateurs et je pense
que nous avons des choses à apporter
regardant le texte anciennement on s'est
battu sur les libertés et en même temps
sur la nécessaire sécurité sur le texte
territoire nous avons repris quoi le
rapport de jean pierre raffarin et du
ratage et les régions on avait dit oui
aux grandes régions à la condition
qu'ils aient des départements qui est
une proximité et que nous préservons ce
qui est la première des proximités et en
ces temps de crise les français en ont
besoin
la commune c'est une idée moderne
aujourd'hui en 70 désarroi et c'est le
fil conducteur du débat qui est en cours
sur la loi sur la nouvelle organisation
territoriale de la république il y aura
une commission mixte paritaire le 9-2
main demain et on aura l'occasion de
voir si nous pouvons converger alors
derrière quelle va être la position du
sénat justement lors de cette commission
mixte paritaire
elle va une position d'abord qui
appartient au rapporte
et au commissaire c'est là où il ya
l'autonomie nous avons la particularité
d'avoir deux rapporteurs sensibilités
différentes jean jacques hyest
républicain rené vandierendonck
socialiste et nous allons essayer plutôt
de construire
nous verrons si par exemple le
gouvernement et la majorité de
l'assemblée nationale veulent imposer le
suffrage universel direct pour les
grands d'intercos et non encore s'il va
là haut conseil du territoire alors
qu'ils allaient feda c'est non mais si
nous pouvons entrer en discussion et les
dresser et c'est en fait le sénat qui a
préservé cette collectivité de proximité
qu'est le département alors l'aréna et
régions les 13 régions là km au 1er
janvier
ça y est c'est m'avait dans la mare
débat entre 13 et 15 mais pardonnez moi
le principe il était dans le rapport
rafa rac ratages et je vais d'ailleurs
participé à ce rapport avant d'être
réélu président du sénat et c'est une
loi je ne dis pas que texte soit parfait
en l'état actuel
mais je vais vous dire ce que je disais
d'ailleurs nicolas sarkozy sait que les
élus sont un peu là toutes ces réformes
territoriales c'est comme là je vais
prendre mon département était un
département dans la partie rurale
on va être en cinq ans ou 4e schéma
directeur de coopération intercommunale
chaque fois les frontières intercos
change tout ceci est une cause de parly
et il est vrai et là je veux partager
avec nicolas sarkozy que le conseiller
territorial c'était vraiment un gars est
là pour l'avenir donc on nous dit s'il
ya alternance de maele s'arrêtera la
réforme territoriale
oui avec les ajustements nécessaires
cette position tout le monde la connaît
de ma part depuis très longtemps
d'accord alors le le le reportage que
nous venons de voir montrait aussi sur
le fond le côté toujours il n'ya pas une
grande nouveauté là dedans clivant de
nicolas sarkozy qui veut qui veut
affirmer nos positions très franches
gouvernement on a vu ce week-end qu'il
était donc en sologne à la fête de la
violette de le côté il ya les
alain juppé qui est peut-être plus
rassembleur en tout cas c'est ce que
disent et soutiens qui m'ont dans une
position de clivage est ce que vous
pensez que d'ici 2010 être d'ici 2017 ça
va se tendre cette opposition d'abord
nicolas sarkozy et le président de notre
mouvement politique
il a été une manière incontestable soeur
et moi j'appartiens au bureau politique
qui a adopté quoi le principe des
primaires et le principe d'un débat qui
se déroule ailleurs chaque semaine je
lui ai fait un peu défaut ce soir pour
vous au bureau politique les primaires
vient d'entrer un peu comme sage à la
commission nationale d'organisation des
primaires et elles se dérouleront en
elles permettront de dégager un candidat
la tipp hauteur de 110 dates mais en
tous les cas c'est plutôt un candidat et
un canton regarde
et puis derrière nous serons autour de
lui rassemblé mais voilà on à nicolas
sarkozy ce week-end qu'il est par
exemple je ne suis pas aveugle je ne
suis pas sourd aux critiques qui
viennent contre moi dans mon camp dans
mon corps évidemment je pense que c'est
le dialogue à l'intérieur du mouvement
politique
il est vrai que sur un certain nombre de
sujets nicolas sarkozy s'exprime d'une
manière forte
alain juppé françois fillon pour
d'autres propositions c'est peut-être
une richesse pour préparer notre projet
politique et nous avons besoin de quoi
aujourd'hui nous gagnons les élections
était le cas les municipales
ça a été le cas les sénatoriales il ya
des heurts avaient réparé te ment talent
c'était avant les européennes avant
qu'est ce qu'on fait on sort les
sortants je voudrais qu'on passe au
moment où on convint où on fait partager
on n'est pas seulement dans le sortir
les sortants et si le travail que nous
devons faire retrouver la confiance pour
éviter en fait le vote 1 parce que je
sens prêt présent dans cette france que
j'ai qualifiée dans mon rapport au
président de la république de france d'à
côté ces gens qui se sont abandonnés
méprisez pas écouté qui vont faire un
vote populiste notamment le front
national qui quoi propose un smic à 15
cents euros qu'ils proposent
et oui la retraite à 60 ans la sortie de
l'euro est en fait ils font la même
chose que le premier ministre grec
il mènerait le pays dans l'impasse
serveuse il faut nous leur montrions que
nous sommes une alternance solide alors
qu'ils petits carnets à mettre en oeuvre
cette année le mouvement
vous avez peut-être la possibilité de
vous exprimer sur le sujet là ce soit
j'ai la possibilité surtout d'incarner
la très bonne organisation des primaires
le respect du principe de la charte et
le moment venu je m'exprimerai le moment
venu vous savez tous que j'ai accompagné
depuis longtemps et philippe seguin dont
françois fillon mais aujourd'hui ma
responsabilité est de faire que la
primaire soit une primaire indiscutable
et indiscuté qui permet de derrière de
choisir le meilleur candidat
v nous rassemblerons françois fillon
n'est pas totalement sortis des radars
n'ont personne n'est sorti des radars
qui connaît la situation en 2016
nous vivons une période que la grande
instabilité international sa et
regardons autour de nous on a parlé de
la grèce est ce que la question des
migrants dont on va parler aujourd'hui
est-ce que ce qui se passe en syrie est
ce que damas ne tomberaient pas dans les
trois semaines un mois peut-être même
avant voilà des sujets
ce matin nous avons reçu le président de
la commission constitutionnelle de la
rada ukrainienne et il est en train de
travailler avec nous en lien avec les
allemands les polonais et moi en lien
avec les rues sont d'accord avec eux
pour essayer de mettre en oeuvre minsk 2
voilà les réalités qu'il nous faut
traiter de manière concrète les soutiens
de françois fillon disent maintenant
depuis quelques temps et notamment
depuis le début malheureusement pour lui
de son déclin son âge et que tout peut
encore arriver mais l'échéance aussi se
rapprochera de la primaire mais on verra
les conditions de déchéance
l'important pour les républicains c'est
d'avoir un candidat qu'ils sachent
qu'ils soient choisis de manière
indiscutable par les polymères qui porte
un projet qui nous rassemblent dans
notre diversité et puis la guerre ça que
nous obtenions la confiance des français
pour notre candidat et pour une majorité
par noël on a ce matin rachida dati qui
fait une interview dans libération et
qui dit que l'ump
elle apporte beaucoup de critiques et a
dit notamment que l'ump en fait enfin
les républicains pardon si oui plutôt
mois les républicains en font trop sur
la question de l'islam de l'immigration
et et quand elle dit les républicains
c'est certainement nicolas sarkozy vous
parliez de convaincre est-ce que c'est
aborder ces sujets sans cesse cliver sur
ces sujets c'est une bonne manière de
vaincre ces sujets il se pose dans mon
rapport je reviens à lui du 15 avril
parmi les quatre sujets identifiés
l'école à l'époque on n'avait pas encore
ce débat si fort et l'échec d'une partie
des jeunes à l'école
la question migratoire je vous le dit
notre capacité à intégrer est
aujourd'hui saturé la question de cette
france abandonné et le fait religieux il
existe vous ne pouvez pas ne pas dire
qu'il n'existe pas et je dois dire qu'il
faut le traiter et que dans une
république laïque comme on l'a fait au
début du 20e siècle
il nous faut traiter non pas le rejet
d'une religion mais au contraire une
religion qui soit compatible avec les
valeurs d'arrêt vous êtes plutôt en
désaccord avec ce que les critiques de
rachida dati je pense qu'il faut traiter
c'est parce que nous ne traitons pas qui
m'a changé qu'on voit on voit monter une
islamophobie insupportable et ça ce
n'est pas possible il nous faut donc
traiter ces sujets la question de la
migration
il faut la traiter parce que pendant
qu'on parle de la grèce ils continuent à
avoir des milliers de migrants et chacun
sait que j'ai été voir le procureur de
catane au mois d'avril ainsi que le
directeur de la police et des rats des
frontières italien
nous voyons bien avant de traiter ce
sujet
vraiment ça c'est la politique c'est ce
qu'attendent nos consciences quoi dire
et et ce serait vraiment c'est je pose
la question parlant de parler de fuite
d'eau comme l'a fait nicolas sarkozy en
évoquant les mijotés c'est pas la
formule que j'aurais utilisé jeux jeux
il est sûre si tu joues renvoie à mon
rapport je pense qu'il faut les traiter
qu'il faut les traiter avec courage
lucidité et que
dans les modes d'expressions qu'on peut
avoir en tous les cas ceux qui ne
veulent pas traiter ces sujets quelque
part ils vont conduire le pays dans tout
ce que j'exècre matériellement
l'incapacité à vivre ensemble pour
reprendre une formule de gauche ou tout
simplement à être en sommes des hommes
et des femmes dont vivons des valeurs de
la république et dans les valeurs de la
république ce que manuel valls qui suite
à l'attentât en isère parle de guerre de
civilisation pour vous participe de ce
traitement des yeux je pense que c'est
pas la bonne formule je pense que dans
la civilisation il ya des humanistes il
ya des humanistes qui n'ont aucune
religion ou qui n'en se réclame d'aucune
il ya des humanistes dans toutes les
religions et il ya malheureusement des
ultras dans toutes les religions même
parfois hors des religions et que cette
dimension de l'humanisme est quelque
chose d'essentiel
il faut que nous gardions ses valeurs de
la république alors à propos de la des
migrants il ya un élu de votre parti le
député eric ciotti qui préconise des
tests osseux pour les mineurs non
accompagnés qui arrivent en france
est-ce que ça c'est une proposition qui
vous choque que vous que vous êtes dans
la nature à soutenir le sujet c'est pas
la radiographie celles âgées theekoye
c'est que nous avons aujourd'hui
migration une migration qui aujourd'hui
n'est plus contrôlé eric ceux qui
parlaient de deux jeunes mineurs ou pas
mineur mais qui tentent de passer la
frontière italienne à calais ils sont
3000 qui évoque cette nuit encore pour
tenter de prendre la navette
1 ces migrants et morts dans un train et
il y en aura d'autres natacha bouchart
sénateur maire de calais vit une
situation absolument insupportable où
elle a le sentiment de l'abandon les
anglais n'en veulent pas et elle se
trouve face à une situation est donc moi
je pense que sur la migration il faut
des quotas
oui mais sur les tests se est ce que
c'était il a déjà ses moyens donc
simplement ce que demande ciotti c'est
que en cas de crise aiguë ont
l'utilisent avec plus de 6 thématiques
mais c'est pas avec ça qu'on va arrêter
le phénomène migratoire phénomène
migratoire
il est aussi les décisions qui doivent
être prises à l'onu
c'est aussi la stabilisation de
l'afrique et personnes on en parle si
peu c'est le co développement l'afrique
de demain matin par exemple dans la
dotation institutionnelle du sénat avec
les présidents nous allons parler
comment nous pouvons aider au
co-développement et le projet de jean
louis borloo j'y reviens souvent pas
simplement par affection pour jean louis
borloo c'est c'est une pierre pour le co
développement
alors vous avez parlé de la france d'un
côté ceux qui se sentent à côté
aujourd'hui ce sont notamment les
éleveurs les agriculteurs ils
multiplient les opérations nocturnes les
nuits de détresse comme ils disent vous
avez décidé d'organiser un véritable
voyage qu'est ce que vous ferez apporter
de plus par à faire honneur
le sénat depuis notamment milieu du
printemps la commission des affaires
économiques la commission des affaires
européennes s'est penché sur la
situation notamment de l'élevage faut
bien mesurer un chiffre qui
accepteraient producteurs de viande - 14
% de revenus en un an
jobs in producteurs de porcs un chiffre
à peu près identique que 13% producteurs
de lait sur les 6 premiers à -19% pardon
sur ces chiffres
mais c'est la vie quotidienne des npai
perdre de l'argent et donc nous avons
des sujets de compétitivité nous avons
des sujets de fiscalité nous avons des
sujets norme qu'est ce que une décision
prise conjointement par les
organisations agricoles et le ministre
pour jouer sur le réseau de la
distribution pour requalifier les prix à
trois semaines n'a eu aucun effet cité
mais s'en était félicité parce que
c'était à l'accord qui aurait dû front
national fait pas marrer bien il n'a pas
marché donc il faut que nous
rassemblions bien sûr la fnsea
bien sûr les acteurs de la filière
bien sûr les distributeurs la
douloureuse y ont un certain nombre de
questions quand je dis des acteurs des
filières alimentaires l'industrie
agroalimentaire simplement un chiffre
qui montre ce malaise est peut être une
malchance pour la france en 2005 la
filière agro alimentaire l'agriculture
française la première en europe
nous sommes la troisième aujourd'hui
derrière l'allemagne et les pays bas
il y a donc des raisons endogènes à la
france c'est pas simplement lié à la
seule europe et il faut qu'on les traite
c'est ce que nous ferons le 16 juillet
parce que c'est la france des
territoires
c'est pas simplement les agriculteurs
c'est cette france des territoires c'est
de france qui a le sentiment qu'au fond
pour reprendre une formule qui m'a été
dit dans le pas de calais on ferait des
lois que pour les villes c'était une
question posée à moi-même et pour moi
c'est une vraie interrogation
merci guillaume à manga a parlé
maintenant justement de la loi taryn
tarnos arrive nous allons donc parler du
travail parlementaire gérard larcher et
sa lenteur qui est reprochée qui vous
est donc reproché à vous comme à d'autre
part le chef de l'état d'abord les
explications de samia de sheer neuf mois
en moyenne c'est presqu'un record en
europe
la fabrication de la loi française est
longue trop longue pour françois
hollande attendre six mois huit mois
parfois davantage pour que la loi soit
votée une lecture de lecture trois
lectures ses différentes lectures
jusqu'à 5 par texte ce sont les allers
retours plus connu sous le nom de
navettes parlementaires entre
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat
autre facteur de ralentissement
l'inflation législative
durant la session 2014 2015 le sénat a
examiné une soixantaine de textes dont
presque la moitié d'origine
gouvernementale mais surtout les textes
sont de plus en plus long exemple
typique la loi macron passé d'une
centaine à plus de 400 articles
chaque parlementaire où le gouvernement
veut apporter un élément nouveau à
l'occasion d'une vote d'une loi et je
crois que c'est un facteur de
ralentissement considérable aussi un jeu
de théâtre où chacun joue son rôle à
coups d'amendements
voilà ce que dénonce françois
cornut-gentille pour lui il est urgent
que les parlementaires passe moins de
temps à produire les lois et plus de
temps à contrôler l'action publique
arrêtons d'être shootée aux textes
législatifs prenant du recul essayons
d'analyser les choses et on fera des
textes législatifs beaucoup plus modérée
il faut une réforme en interne pas
forcément des institutions pour que les
commissions le travail parlementaire
soit davantage tourné vers le contrôle
ça on a besoin d'autorisation personne
suffit de décider nous mêmes pour tenter
de rationaliser les débats le sénat
vient de modifier son fonctionnement en
favorisant par exemple le travail en
commissions ou encore en limitant les
temps de parole des réformettes pour
alexis bachelez comme d'autres députés
il appelle à une profonde réforme des
institutions
moi je prône la suppression du sénat
sous sa forme actuelle
ça ne veut pas dire qu'on n'a pas besoin
d'une deuxième chambre mais moi je pense
qu'il ya plusieurs propositions
intéressantes qui sont sur la table à
celle de claude bartolone de fusionner
le conseil économique et senna il y en a
il ya d'autres propositions d'avoir
peut-être un collège à l'intérieur de ce
sénat de gens tirent au sort ou d'en
faire la représentation des régions
une proposition controversée et qui
n'est de toute façon pour l'instant pas
à l'ordre du jour
voilà sur ces questions donc c'est
perrine tarneaud qui va vous interrogez
gérard larcher bonsoir perena michel
alors là par la procédure parlementaire
serait donc trop lents dans tout cas
c'est ce que semble découvrir françois
hollande qui a quand même si j'ai une
vingtaine d'années à l'assemblée
nationale est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec ce constat pas du tout j'étais lui
dire
lundi dernier nous avons eu un long
tête-à-tête et parmi les sujets y avait
des sujets de politique internationale
et il y avait ce sujet d'abord je suis
venu avec quelques statistiques depuis
la réforme constitutionnelle de 2008 la
procédure accélérée qui est devenue la
procédure habituelle les spectateurs on
est passé de 5 - 4 à 5 mois et on est
passé pour un texte qui a deux lectures
dans chaque chambre d'un peu plus de 9
mois et demi à 9 mois le vrai sujet
c'est d'abord le formidable décalage
qu'il ya entre l' annonce en conseil des
ministres et le dépôt du texte devant
l'assemblée nationale où où le sénat je
lui citer l'exemple de la loi
biodiversité dont on parlera à l'automne
savez vous qu'elle a été déposée en mars
2014 parents de mars 2015
alors c'est la faute à qui ça veut dire
que c'est le gouvernement qui pose pour
passer ces textes qui fait des textes
chez le gouvernement une annonce et ne
le dépose pas devant le bureau d'une
assemblée comme il en a la possibilité
donc le temps l'exécutif est différente
c'est bien sûr parce qu'il est dans un
temps danon son 2e des choses quand vous
arrivez des textes qui ont plus de 100
articles la loi comme le texte 106 ou
comme le texte santé qui va nous arriver
pour le mois de septembre
260 pages comment voulez vous que le
temps parlementaire
alors donc c'est la faute des
gouvernements qui finalement entassés
sur des responsables de part de
responsabilités du départ du
gouvernement
et puis il ya la responsabilité aussi du
parlement voilà pourquoi nous avons
proposé et nous mettons en oeuvre depuis
le 29 juin
c'est un petit ouvrage mieux organiser
le travail sénatorial nouvelles règles
nouvelles habitudes et nous réduisons
les temps de manière forte par deux et
le temps moyen est devenu de 2 minutes
30 pour des interventions il va falloir
aussi qu'on réfléchisse ce que je
partage avec françois cornut-gentille
c'est notamment une des missions du
sénat la fonction de contrôle et une
fonction tout à fait importante parce
qu'au fond les gens il croît de bonne
foi qu'annoncé au conseil des ministres
à loi va être mis en oeuvre très très
vite et il sa personne que macron on en
parlait à l'été 2014 et que nous aurons
un texte et d'éventuels décret c'est à
la rentrée 2 millions et il ya eu en
plus le 49-3 parce que la majorité
gouvernementale ne souhaitait pas voté
majoritairement madame le texte vous en
avait parlé à françois hollande il a
reconnu ses torts pour le gouvernement
il a salué les mais le sujet
indiqué ce qui vous a le sujet je lui ai
laissé ce numéro 0 de ce petit ouvrage
pour lui montrer le travail
c'est vrai qu'il faut qu'on améliore
aussi le fonctionnement du travail entre
la commission et la séance pour rendre
d'ailleurs la séance plus vivante plus
intéressante
nous le voyons bien donc je travaille
deux fois en fait soit fait en
commission et non plus tellement dans
les meetings qu être dans les 2 c nous
savons bien que c'est dans un dialogue
mais il ya un certain nombre de textes
où le travail en commission peut
permettre des plus approfondies
d'où la réalité à partir du 1er octobre
quand la commission sera en vote
législatif
il est demandé aux parlementaires avec
de participer aux travaux que
répondez-vous aux mises en cause de
certains députés qui vise le sénat on va
écouter je peux leur proposer une
formule on supprime l'assemblée pour que
les assemblées ont fait des décret loi
et la démocratie et disparaît je pense
que la deuxième
maintenant des jeux c'est pas la
deuxième chambre c'est tout à fait
essentiel notamment depuis la réforme du
quinquennat
je le redis l'assemblée nationale c'est
la réplique sismique
regardez un texte le texte sur le
renseignement
s'il n'y avait pas eu le sénat et c'est
d'ailleurs et en lecture
j'allais dire une seule lecture
procédure accélérée
la dimension liberté n'auraient pas été
prises en compte par le vote de
l'assemblée nationale
ça me renvoie à l'autonomie du sénat et
si j'ai saisi le conseil constitutionnel
c'est parce que du fait que n'y avait
qu'une seule lecture devant le sénat
je voulais m'assurer que les libertés
essentielles qui est une des
responsabilités du sénat libertés
individuelles liberté collective et ça
ça mérite autre chose qu'une
approximation dans là que j'ai entendu
de la part d'un député des
hauts-de-seine défendre des libertés
c'est la mission numéro un du sénat de
la part représentée les lectures
effectivement de l'assemblée nationale
et du sénat et celui du conseil
constitutionnel
c'est pour vous n'avez pas le sentiment
quand même actuellement gérard larcher
que sous cette petite musique de la
procédure parlementaire est trop lente
ce n'est pas en fait le bicamérisme qui
visait et donc le sénat je pense que
c'est surtout les chais respectifs de
dieu je pense que c'est aussi l'échec de
la politique gouvernementale
puisqu'il faut bien affûté à d'autres à
ce qui ralentirait
l'absence de résultats de la politique
gouvernementale je le dis il faut pas en
faire du bicamérisme un espèce dans jeux
politiciens pour un rendez vous de 2010
est autant moi je suis ouvert au débat
sur le nombre de parlementaires dont je
rappelle que c'est françois mitterrand
qui l'a augmentée là il faudra ouvrir la
réflexion je suis en train même de
l'ouvrir au nombre de parlements douleur
d'ajuster le nombre de parlementaires
avec une notion que nous à la base et la
représentativité du territoire nous
n'avons qu'un système basé sur la
démographie moi je dis qu'il faut que le
territoire est celle-là ça sur l'année
quoi concrètement ont repéré les
chiffres on ne vais pas les coupures
avant d avoir commencé toute façon un
ajustement constitutionnelle entre
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat pour
le vote du congrès voilà et ça sera et
ça sera nécessaire notamment avec
l'application la limitation du cumul en
c'est un autre sujet ça oui mais à notre
sujet et des autres sujets ça n'est pas
directement lié et moi personnellement
je pense que au contraire il faut se
poser la question comment on fait mieux
la loi la procédure accélérée n'est pas
une très bonne procédure
comment on travaille mieux en commission
comment on a des séances plus dynamique
ça c'est la vraie responsabilité mais
dire je suis là il faut supprimer
l'autre ça n'a pas de sens je pense que
le bicamérisme voulu par le général de
gaulle bien voulu par le général de
gaulle dans la réforme constitutionnelle
de 58 qui a institué la vème république
c'est à balancier cette dette s'y attend
pas ce que vous sentez le danger
toujours présent trouver il faut d'abord
changer la constitution c'est pas une
mince affaire
la deuxième des choses je ne suis pas
sûre que mon pays est en démocratie en
représentation un moment où il va mal à
un moment où ils doutent des politiques
souvenez vous d'une seule chose les
seuls élus qui ont la confiance
majoritaire des français sur les mers
merdes juin les conseils municipaux pour
conclure quand même cette procédure
parlementaire gérard larcher une
dernière question parce que tout se sait
pas quand même l'échec de la réforme
constitutionnelle de 2008 celle de
nicolas sarkozy qui voulait donner plus
de pouvoir au parlement
et ils l'ont m'a donné plus de poids au
parlement et notamment la capacité
de contrôler et il faut que le parlement
s'en saisissent plus et c'est d'ailleurs
une des fonctions du sénat et ce sur
quoi nous allons sans doute marqué la
session prochaine plus de contrôle
claude bartolone quittera l'automne la
présidence de l'assemblée la salle pour
faire campagne pour les élections
régionales en ligne de france
est ce que vous êtes heureux de voir
partir l'homme qui voulait justement
supprimer le sénat noro pense que j'ai
de bons rapports avec claude bartolone
on avait cru comprendre que j'étais un
peu tendu pendant notre jeu nous sommes
en désaccord total il voulait la 6ème
république
moi je suis pour la cinquième et le
président de la république a pu mesurer
que la cinquième nuit était pas inutile
dans ces temps de crise crise extérieure
notamment sur la décision militaire
politique étrangère ça n'est pas inutile
mais aussi décision intérieur
l'opération décidée notamment pour
protéger un certain nombre de lieux en
france une opération sentinel tous à la
vème république permet au président le
49-3 c'est l'utilisation d'un cinquième
réglé non nous avons une conception de
la république différentes
il n'empêche que nous sommes je le crois
où les deux des hommes responsables et
tous voulons faire fonctionner les
institutions
justement vous avez quel président la
république et paraître françois hollande
rêve de versailles il pourrait convoquer
le parlement en congrès au début de
l'année 2016 pour notamment ratifié la
charte sur les langues régionales
ce texte passera au sénat sans doute à
l'automne prochain vous y est favorable
je lui ai dit que non sont les langues
régionales parce que nous avons déjà
réformés en 2008 pour permettre aux
langues régionales de s'exprimer je
pense que ce sujet là est un sujet à un
moment où notre pays se fragmente se
fracture à des replis communautaires
j'évoquais tout à l'heure fait religieux
qui sont migratoires
l'échec à l'école je pense que notre
pays a d'abord besoin de se rassembler
et de se retrouver
je pense que ce n'est pas le sujet le
sujet de l'urgence dans un pays qui doit
d'abord retrouver le chemin de la
confiance de l'emploi et de reformer une
communauté nationale qui se retrouve une
atteinte à l'unicité janvier
résidents de la république je n'ai pas
dit que c'était une atteinte à la
république attendu ça c'est michel
grossiord faut chaque fin de niveau des
mesures et les mots moi je suis un homme
dont on a dit qu'il était rond quand je
dis non c'est vrai d'ailleurs quand je
dis non c'est le nom d' antigone si il
est rare et c'est donc mec je dis que
sur ce sujet ça n'est pas un sujet
d'actualité donc que nous avions fait
des progrès en 2008 sur cette question
car il n'est pas illégitime
c'est un acquis pour notre patrimoine
pour la diversité de nos territoires
mais nous avons d'abord besoin nous
retrouver avant d'envisager tout cela
sénateurs ne sont pas favorables a pas
de majorité à 30 des trois un canyon
d'autres sujets les deux autres sujets
d'accords sont envisagés que reçoit
notamment la réforme du conseil
supérieur de la magistrature et je pense
que tous ces sujets là il faut que le
président de la république en parle avec
eux et le premier ministre avec les deux
présidents de commissions liées ainsi la
fin du statut de membre à vie au conseil
constitutionnel des présentes la
république ça vous y seraient favorables
ou pas vous y seriez il y aura un
ensemble de choses
personnellement sur ces sujets il ya
déjà eu des propositions du sénat on
laissera les présidents de commission
des lois les commissions des lois
réfléchir d'accord est la laïcité qui
est chère aux sénateurs gérard larcher
la mairie de paris a organisé une nuit
du ramadan est ce que c'est à une
collectivité territoriale dargani long
mais ces types d abord à voix au débat
surréaliste qu'on a eu en décembre sur
les crèches eux
je pense que le fait religieux il exhibe
les crèches dans certaines collectivités
aient tous été surréaliste la banque ou
rendez compte avant le 7 8 et 9 janvier
où nous avons vu et donc je crois que la
république laïque doit pouvoir
s'affirmer que personnellement je pense
qu'il faut que dans l'espace public nous
soyons très attentifs aux expressions
religieuses n'ont pas les interdire mais
très attentif mais en même temps il faut
qu'on soit attentif à permettre à chacun
c'est la loi de 1905 et c'est
l'arbitrage entre combes et brillant à
l'époque je suis plutôt du côté de
brillantes
ce cas là est ce que chacun puisse
librement exercer le culte de son choix
ou de ne pas exercer de culte à la
condition qu'ils respectent les
principes et les valeurs de la
république c'était générale anne hidalgo
d'organiser cet événement tous les cas
j'ai quelque peu souri parce que entre
se rendre en avion on a lu religieux ce
qui nous arrive tous ce qui nous arrive
tous où le faire dans sa propre mairie
je voudrais être sûr que le tribunal
administratif et la même attention la
même vigilance qu'ils avaient eu pour
une crèche vendée est là et c'était en
tout cas qu'elle n'interdit pas de
s'engager pour les chrétiens d'orient 1
le sénat est notamment notamment - même
pour les chrétiens d'orient nous avons
fait il ya peu dans le journal la croix
une tribune sur ce sujet les chrétiens
d'orient
c'est au delà même d'un choix religieux
un message un message de la diversité de
la minorité de valeur dans une capacité
dans des lieux où il ya la diversité
religieuse à partager un certain nombre
d'éléments de la vie en commun plutôt
qu'un s'opposer c'est un message
c'est un message de liberté c'est un
message humaniste des chrétiens d'orient
et quand vous lisez dans le rapport du
député malek boutih qu'il ya un risque
de radicalisation il existe je veux
aujourd'hui chez les jeunes français
mais qu'il évoque un possible phénomène
de masse demain comment réagissez-vous
jaj lorsque son analyse n'est pas
erronée et sur mon analyse n'est pas
erroné il va falloir que nous proposions
un certain nombre de valeurs pas falloir
que le but you contre le chômage des
jeunes vraiment ça c'est une vraie
priorité il va falloir aussi que nous
soyons exigeants sur l'intégration et
pourquoi pas le mot c'est dans le code
civil
l'assimilation ce qui veut pas dire
nulles et les origines dont on vient on
à chacun une histoire qu'il n'a pas
toujours été gauloise mais je pense que
la solution de boutih n'est pas la bonne
je pense que c'est la laïcité qui nous
permet de réussir
merci jacques et merci perrine merci à
tous bon soir a très vite